buon pomeriggio a tutti
questa parte della conferenza si
intitola dalla tradizione alla modernità
io ho una certa idiosincrasia quando
vado a vedere biennali o mostre
collettive e si vede il lavoro di
artisti che hanno portato se stessi
invece di portare qualcosa che è
inerente al tema perché mi sembra che
sono stati o un po pigri un po annoiati
o non hanno voluto rispettare le
intenzioni o del curatore o anche la
presenza del pubblico che è venuto a
sentirli quindi io cercherò di
raccontare uno spaccato della mia vita
professionale che può diventare senza
nessuna pretesa una piccola metafora del
mio rapporto con la tradizione alla
modernità circa quattro anni fa ho
affrontato il problema che molti artisti
a un certo punto della propria che
arriva devono affrontare che è quella di
una mostra di un servizio che raccolga
in qualche modo tutte le idee i progetti
che questo artista elaborato nel corso
degli ultimi 10 15 anni e quindi insieme
alle persone che lavorano con me abbiamo
concepito questo progetto intitolato the
trinity suddiviso in tre parti in
collaborazione con tre musei che si
sarebbe dovuto focalizzare su tre
aspetti fondamentali del mio lavoro
il cinema l'arte cioè lo studio del
linguaggio cinematografico del
linguaggio artistico e la religione
quindi in collaborazione con il maxxi
con il nuovo psn con il moca di los
angeles
abbiamo elaborato il progetto the
trinity per quanto riguarda il maxxi con
galleria vezzoli abbiamo operato una
specie di trasformazione del museo in
una pseudo galleria borghese e abbiamo
esposto i miei lavori per quanto
riguarda il moca abbiamo cercato di
trasformarlo in una specie di cinema e
ci siamo in qualche modo riusciti con
velluti sedute da cinema arazzi
proiezioni poste eccetera
e poi siamo arrivati al progetto che
fossero la parte conclusiva e più
eclatante che era quello prospettato per
il moma ps1
il progetto per il moma ps1 consisteva
nel tra virgolette tentativo di prendere
le rovine di una chiesa sconsacrata e in
rovina quindi senza tetto e senza senza
possibilità d'uso alcuno e the
costruirla fisicamente e portarla e
ricostruirla all'interno della corte del
del moma ps1 purtroppo delle
vicissitudini legali ci hanno diciamo
fisicamente impedito di portare a
termine il progetto
sono stato indagato grazie all'abilità
dei miei avvocati alla mia buona fede io
penso che sia così sono il caso è stato
completamente archiviato e quindi a un
certo punto del lavoro
io mi sono trovato che in qualche modo
con un certo rispetto diciamo anche
forse non dico successo però le prime
due parti di questo progetto erano state
portate a termine e mi trovavo a questo
punto a confrontarmi con il moma che per
definizione è il tempio che definisce la
modernità e mi trovavo senza un'idea c'è
la mia idea iniziale molto forte di
portare una parte della nostra storia
legata alle nostre radici culturali
religiose emotive all'interno di questo
territorio era svanita e non poteva
essere ripetuto non poteva essere
ricreata e quindi diciamo mi sono
trovato dentro questo problema cosa
posso portare al moma ps1 che racconti
la mia modernità
ho pensato il passato la tradizione ma
cosa c'è di ancora più tradizionale
antico emotivo delle rovine di una
chiesa allora ho pensato al passato non
prossimo ma al passato remoto
ciao passato alla romanità e allora che
cosa ha fatto ho iniziato anche con una
certa ansia diciamo perché il tempo
stava stringendo a comprare come un
qualunque diciamo benestante anche se io
non lo ero collezionista a tutte le aste
di antichità di software bis di
christie's delle teste possibilmente che
risalissero al primo secondo secolo dopo
cristo quindi piena romanità piena
classicità e poi mi sono confrontato col
fatto che la scultura romana
nell'architettura romana ma anche quella
greca
in origine molto spesso erano completate
da un aspetto cromatico che poi il tempo
ha portato via
non dico una cosa che ha né rilevanza né
originalità né accademica e scientifica
lo sanno tutti il partenone era dipinto
l'ara pacis della quale parleremo dopo
era dipinta molte delle sculture erano
dipinte e nelle varie etichette dei
musei più importanti del mondo si può
leggere qui si vede una traccia di
pigmento rosso che ci racconta appunto
che questa scultura era tutta colorata
eccetera eccetera
ma tutte queste emozioni di questi
strati di colore sono state portate via
dal tempo e quindi la tradizione ci ha
lasciati con delle architetture e delle
sculture che sono per la maggior parte
dei casi bianche obese o grigie che
ricordano diciamo un'idea di classicità
che è fasulla che sembra più uno spot
per un profumo di calvin klein degli
anni 80 che quello che invece era la
classicità nella sua realtà
allora mi sono rivolto ad uno dei più
importanti accademici attualmente
diciamo al lavoro nel mondo che si
chiama clemente marconi che la cattedra
di archeologia online news
e con lui ho cercato di elaborare una
possibile colorazione di queste sculture
e abbiamo proceduto in questo senso mi è
sembrato che questo poteva essere
l'unico gesto che poteva compensare per
la privazione della chiesa la chiesa già
mi sembrava un gesto profondamente
radicale ma questa idea di ricolorare il
passato nemmeno mi sembrava compensasse
mi sembrava un gesto che poteva avere lo
stesso lo stesso tasso di radicalità
intensità pericolo e l'abbiamo appunto
portato a termine
per me è stato un gesto molto importante
perché appunto
ho l'impressione che quando guardiamo al
passato noi un po ne vogliamo ne subiamo
una versione edulcorata ripulita invece
quando tu approccio una scultura antica
e comincia a ricolorare negli occhi di
colore dalla pelle che accorgi che
queste sculture erano oggettivamente è
veicolo di desiderio di passione
diventano vive diventano come degli
scatti di instagram e quindi capisce
anche che tutto il rapporto tra l'essere
umano e l'arte non è un rapporto
filtrato dall'aula dalla paura dalla
musealità ma nel nei secoli passati il
rapporto con l'arte era un rapporto
molto più diciamo sensuale erotico
oggettivo finanziario non non
necessariamente intellettuale o
accademico
quindi diciamo la mia metafora si chiude
in maniera molto semplice dicendo che
quando nella mia storia ho avuto paura o
una grande sicurezza perché non sapevo
come affrontare la modernità e il tempio
che a livello internazionale definisce
l'idea di modernità
io mi sono dovuto riagganciare alla
tradizione ho dovuto acquistare tra
virgolette qualcosa di assolutamente
tradizionale e antico ho dovuto
ricolorare lo quindi l'ho dovuto rendere
contemporaneo ma a quel punto non era
più contemporaneo
è una parola che a me non interessa
molto era diventato presente e quando mi
sono rimesso a guardare a queste statue
o mi sono ho creduto di sentirmi più o
meno come si poteva sentire una persona
del passato quando le guardava duemila
anni fa
vi ringrazio